[Music]
tonight's program is a tale of two
papers each written by albert einstein
each written in 1935 and each according
to einstein
on completely different
totally unrelated subjects
the tale of these two papers went its
way right up to the present as some
scientists now propose that these two
papers are actually
intimately connected a proposal with
profound implications for our
understanding of the small quantum
mechanics
and our understanding of the large
einstein's general theory of relativity
some background
prior to the 1900s we seemingly had a
perfectly good understanding of the laws
governing the physical universe handed
down to us by the great isaac newton
these
are the laws we still teach high school
kids around the world the laws of
so-called classical physics
and for those of you who like math here
are
some of the essential equations but
those are details
at the core of newton's perspective is
the idea that if you specify how the
world is right now
the positions and velocities of all
ingredients and you specify
the forces acting on those ingredients
the laws predict how the world will be
at any subsequent moment the framework
it's it's sleek it's elegant it's
powerful and it's rigid in its
determination of the future and
it worked the predictions about the
future where
a pendulum would be as it swung where a
ball would land when thrown where the
moon would be in its orbit around the
earth all of these predictions and every
other that was made all of them were
spot on accurate that is
until the early years of the 20th
century when scientists
gained the capacity to explore
the micro world the world of of
molecules of atoms and subatomic
particles because in this realm
the predictions from newton's math were
they were wrong
the data revealed that new rules were
needed to understand the microscopic
realm and remarkably within
just a few decades
a generation of scientists including the
likes of
albert einstein
max planck
niels bohr werner heisenberg irwin
schrodinger max born and many others
this group of brilliant thinkers ushered
in a new understanding called quantum
mechanics now quantum mechanics it comes
with its own powerful
mathematical formulation but again one
can grasp the central new idea of
quantum mechanics even without the math
whereas
newton said
tell me how the world is now and i will
tell you how the world will be tomorrow
quantum mechanics says tell me how the
world is now and i'll tell you the
probability that the world will be one
way or the other tomorrow and according
to quantum mechanics
these probabilities provide the deepest
and most precise description of the
physical unfolding
god completely gone according to quantum
mechanics was the rigid certainty of the
classical world now
much has been made of einstein's
resistance to the probabilistic nature
of quantum mechanics the
famous and frequently quoted
god does not play dice
but einstein did not deny that quantum
probabilities provided a spectacularly
accurate description of the microscopic
realm instead
he firmly believed that quantum
mechanics was only
a provisional theory one that would
ultimately be replaced by a deeper
understanding that would not rely on
probabilities
and toward this end einstein
he worked tirelessly to expose
qualities of quantum mechanics that he
hoped would be
so
obviously unacceptable so
counter to any reasonable person's
expectation of how the world works
that everyone would have to agree with
his view that quantum mechanics was not
the final story and in 1935 with two
colleagues
boris podolski and nathan rosen einstein
believed he had finally found the
ultimate quantum mechanical achilles
heel with a property inherent to quantum
mechanics called
quantum entanglement briefly put
einstein his colleagues found that
according to the math of quantum
mechanics if two objects
interact
and then
widely separate
a subsequent measurement on one of those
objects revealing one or another quality
would have an instantaneous influence on
the other object regardless of the
distance between them
einstein called this strange
quantum connection he called it spooky
spooky action at a distance and
it troubled him deeply his his
straightforward
intuitive belief was that widely
separated objects are independent of one
another but quantum entanglement
seemingly denied that by providing
an invisible quantum connection capable
of linking the distant objects together
or as the name says
entangling them
einstein could not accept this quantum
view of reality and so
he concluded that
something had to give quantum mechanics
could not be the full
and final story that's the upshot of the
1935
so-called epr paper now i want you to
note the date on this paper
may 1935
in july of 1935 einstein and rosen
published another paper on a seemingly
completely different subject
years earlier in 1915
einstein had ripped another rug out from
under the newtonian worldview showing
that newton's approach to gravity needed
to be replaced by his own
general theory of relativity in which
the force of gravity which newton
quantified but never explained is
finally laid bare to move under the
influence of gravity according to
einstein is to surf the warps
and curves
in space-time
now
shortly after einstein announced this
general theory of relativity to the
world
a german scientist named carl
schwarzschild found the first exact
solution to einstein's new equation
showing how a spherical body like a star
warps its environment
and within that solution is a startling
realization if a if a spherical body is
crushed to a small enough size the
space-time curvature is so extreme that
a kind of
point of no return forms if anything
crosses this so-called event horizon
it's impossible to escape the
gravitational pull even even a beam of
light can't escape so the region appears
dark we have what modern parlance is
called
a black hole
in his 1935 paper with rosen
einstein wasn't actually thinking about
black holes but it turns out the black
holes provide the right language for the
modern interpretation of the result
which is this
einstein and rosen found that two black
holes
can be joined together in space-time
connecting one region of the universe
to another through a kind
of bridge what we now call
an einstein
rosen bridge or perhaps a more popular
terminology
a wormhole
now wormholes have been a staple of
science fiction but they're also an
arena of scientific study although they
are still surely fully hypothetical
theoretical physicists have learned a
great deal about wormholes in the
intervening decades but
here is the thing
were you to have asked any of those
researchers if there was
any connection between wormholes and
einstein's other 1935 paper the one on
quantum entanglement
they would have said no
at least until
very recently as a surprising new
connection has been proposed a proposal
with potentially far-reaching
consequences
not just for black holes
but even for the very structure of space
and time themselves
tonight we are honored to have three
guests who will lead us through the
wonderful worlds of general relativity
quantum mechanics black holes
entanglement and some of the
cutting-edge developments that may link
these ideas together
our first guest is mark von ramsdonk who
is a professor of physics at the
university of british columbia
he was a canada research chair a sloan
foundation fellow is currently a simon's
investigator and is a recipient of the
canadian
capcrm medal in theoretical and
mathematical physics he joins us now
from vancouver welcome mark next we have
anna alonso serrano a postdoctoral
researcher at the max planck institute
for gravitational physics
her work lies at the interface between
gravitational theory and quantum theory
including aspects of the black hole
information paradox thermodynamics of
space-time as well as notions of entropy
quantum cosmology quantum field theory
and wormhole she joins us from berlin
welcome anna
and finally we have leonard suskin the
felix block professor of theoretical
physics at stanford university
he's a member of the national academy of
sciences the american academy of arts
and sciences an associate member of the
faculty of canada's perimeter institute
for theoretical physics
and a distinguished professor at the
korea institute for advanced study
suskine is one of the founders of string
theory and is widely regarded as one of
the most influential physicists of our
time i could go on but suffice it to say
that without suskin's profound
contributions
many of the key ideas that we will be
discussing here tonight simply put they
would not be known
he joins us from his home in stanford
california
welcome lenny and welcome to you all
let's
jump right in and discuss einstein's
1935 paper on quantum entanglement and
so
mark
what do you think what motivated
einstein to write this paper was he
trying to advance our understanding of
quantum mechanics or perhaps was he
trying to kind of
undercut it entirely yeah i mean i was
looking over that paper again last night
and uh it's it's really clear that he's
he's
uncomfortable with some aspects of
quantum mechanics uh he's he's trying to
show in a sense that uh the current
understanding of quantum mechanics can't
be complete he he uh with his colleagues
feels that maybe there's something wrong
with it and it's it's like he's they've
found the
the thing that will will maybe
prove that there's got to be something
more there that maybe there's some extra
information in addition to the wave
function
yeah so so lenny you know there's this
interesting
historical fact that schroedinger long
before the 1935 paper he said something
like i don't have the exact words but he
said something like entanglement is not
one but the feature of quantum mechanics
that distinguishes it from a classical
worldview do you agree with that
assessment of entanglement
yes i i think that's fair i think that's
fair um to say that entanglement
it's certainly the most peculiar and um
different thing about quantum mechanics
i think it's fair to say it's the
central core of the um
of the difference between classical
physics and quantum mechanics
so ana i'm just curious because i think
of all the the folks participating in
this conversation
i think you and i have perhaps the
greatest age differential
when i was an undergraduate
entanglement never came up
it wasn't in the lecture and it was a it
was a good class i went to like a good
place it wasn't in the textbook
how about how about for you
did you learn entanglement in your first
course in quantum mechanics
yeah that's a great question because it
was something uh it surprised me a lot
in fact not really at the beginning it
was something that appeared
pretty late for what
it is as uh was said before that being
the most peculiar and characteristic
point
uh was not so much mentioned and i was
also surprised like uh neither any
of the history of how quantum mechanics
was developed and the this
point that was erased by einstein and
the different ideas about interpretation
of quantum mechanics and it's not
something that you are
teaching right now neither in a
bachelor or a degree so yeah so mark
we've said a few words about and damn we
haven't actually said what it is so can
you just give us uh your best
description of what quantum entanglement
is actually all about
yeah absolutely so i think the
underlying idea here is the quantum
superposition idea i would say
that in some sense is the core of
quantum mechanics that if if you have a
physical system and it can exist in
two different configurations then
quantum mechanics says that it could
also exist
in
what we call quantum superpositions of
those configurations so let's say i had
a
classical object like a coin it could
you flip it it could be heads it could
be tails
and in quantum mechanics
what we say is that well it could also
be in all of these other configurations
that are
part heads part tails they don't have a
definite result until you go and and you
you interact with that system and
measure it to see if it's heads if it's
tails so so that's sort of the basis and
then with quantum entanglement it's just
applying that to systems that have
multiple parts so maybe you look at
two of these coins now and if you flip
both of those then in quantum mechanics
you could have
weird combinations like partly heads
tails partly tails heads so there's all
these different combinations and
the idea with quantum entanglement if
you go in and measure that if you go and
look what are the coins saying then if
you find heads for the first one then
you're definitely going to find heads
for the second one if you find tails for
the first one you'll definitely find
tails for the second one so it's this
correlation between
the two states
even though either one of those things
is
uncertain
right right and and because these
correlations they hold regardless of how
far apart the objects may be einstein
famously described this as spooky as
spooky action at a distance right you do
a measurement on one of these coins or
one of these particles and it has a kind
of
instantaneous impact on the partner you
you measure one coin you find heads the
other one is definitely heads or
definitely tails whatever the
configuration of the objects may be but
but einstein himself
seemed to focus on
another aspect a related aspect of
quantum entanglement which is this in
composite systems you can know
everything that there is to know about
that composite system and yet not know
anything specific about the individual
pieces now lenny is is that a part of
entanglement that you think is really
more at the essence of quantum
entanglement than spooky action at a
distance
yes uh
that's exactly the way i think about
entanglement and what's weird about it
that you can know you have two systems
my two hands
uh you know god gave us thumbs what a
lucky thing one up
one down or one down one up and so forth
okay an entangled state of my thumbs
is a very peculiar thing it could be
both of them can be up both of them down
they can be pointing toward you they can
be pointing away from you
and so forth
an entangled state is exactly what you
said it's a situation where you can know
everything that can be known
everything that can be known that nature
that the rules of quantum mechanics say
that you can know you can know
everything that can be known
about the composite system and know
nothing at all about either of its parts
now how can that be i'm absolutely
certain that that's what freaked
einstein out
how can it be that you know everything
that can be known about the composite
system and know nothing about the parts
what do i mean about not knowing
anything about the parts
well you simply if you make a
measurement on one on your on this thumb
here
it's randomly up or down
if you make a measurement on the other
thumb it's randomly up or down
you know nothing about it on the other
hand you know something else you know
correlation
you know that if one thumb is up then
the other one is down if one thumb is
down then the other one is up or
something like that
so einstein felt deeply that
this could not be the end of the story
he understood quantum mechanics there's
no doubt that he completely understood
this
uh
and
wasn't in the dark about what all this
meant
he simply couldn't
he couldn't come to terms with the idea
that you could know everything that can
be known about a system and know nothing
at all about its parts
um that was deep that was extremely deep
and um we're still seeing the
repercussions of it today
very much so in fact
and and so anna if it freaked out
einstein
right does it freak out you this this
idea that quantum mechanics describes
composite systems in this strange way
yeah of course i think
i think nobody that have
learned quantum mechanics can say that
was not freaking out first time that
was uh learning these things
and i think getting the from our
classical world where we are used to
think and to have intuition
it's not easy to change our minds to uh
learn how to take intuition of that i
think it's a
change of the tip i'm thinking about
that system that they say that is a
non-separable system is uh that's the
one of the key words is the
non-separability there of the
of the whole system so then you cannot
know individually anything completely so
mark
historically speaking what did einstein
do
with this freaked out reaction to
quantum mechanics did he just leave it
at that did he have a potential solution
where was he hoping he could push the
field by emphasizing this weird
quality of quantum systems yeah so
einstein
thought that
this idea that you could have
an entangled state
widely separated
where the two parts were so far apart
that they weren't interacting at all so
then the idea that you could measure one
part and then immediately know what's
going on with the other part
specifically in the paper they they just
tried to show that they tried to show a
contradiction
that the standard uh story in quantum
mechanics with a pair of particles uh so
so there's the heisen per uncertainty
principle statement that you can't know
the momentum and the position at the
same time so they wanted to set up kind
of a contradiction to show that
if you have one of these entangled pairs
of particles
then by
looking at one of the two particles in
different ways you could either say look
at the momentum and then you would know
the momentum of the other one because of
the entanglement
or you could look at the position and
then you would know the position of the
other one because of the entanglement
and then they go on to say that well
because i could have done either one of
those things and because well there's no
way that that could have had an have an
effect on the other side because it's
not interacting it's too far separated
then they suggest
that uh well that's that sort of shows
that you could know both the momentum
and the position of the other one and
that's sort of a contradiction with the
heisenberg uncertainty principles so
things just don't seem self-consistent
right i guess with the idea being that
if somehow a measurement in new york
is telling you something about a
particle in los angeles
then it must be according to einstein
and colleagues that the particle in los
angeles always had that quality
even if quantum mechanics wasn't able to
tell you what that quality was it can't
be that what you do in new york is
literally bringing that quality to a
definite
circumstance that just seems kind of
crazy and it's an interesting historical
fact again
that's worth noting
einstein wasn't very happy with the epr
paper this is this wonderful quote which
i happen to have
here
because schroedinger wrote einstein a
letter after the epr paper kind of uh
congratulating him on it that was a
really good observation einstein then
writes back to schroedinger here's what
he says he goes i was very pleased with
your detailed letter which speaks about
the little essay the essay being the
1935 epr paper then einstein goes on for
reasons of language this was written by
podolski after many discussions but
still it has not come out as well as i
really wanted
on the contrary the main point was so to
speak
buried by the erudition
so
he he wasn't thrilled with how this this
paper turned out
and lenny i think it's because
einstein wasn't pleased as mark
recounted
that the epr paper focuses on heisenberg
uncertainty principle
it focuses upon a counterfactual right
it imagines that you could measure this
or you could measure that
you know a contrarian can say well you
can't measure them both on the first
particle so can you really draw any
inference about the qualities of the
second so he saw this as much more
general i think than what the epr paper
even even discussed is that your take on
it as well yeah very much so um
you know the the letters epr we all know
what they stand for right
when i first learned about it i was told
that epr stood for elements of physical
reality
which is a term that appears in their
paper
when i learned about epr it was elements
of physical reality
and it was very clear that that was what
was bothering einstein what is real what
is real what uh what is at the bottom of
everything
what is really unambiguous what is um
objective
as opposed to what's uh in our minds and
what we decide to measure and don't
decide to measure and so forth
what is real einstein was a realist i
mean he was a realist and that he
believed always deeply that there's
something real
and something underlying
that is
objective almost classical
yet he knew that quantum mechanics
didn't work that way
i don't know that quant that einstein
was trying to overthrow quantum
mechanics or that he was trying to find
a contradiction
i more or less read the paper as just
saying isn't this very weird this can't
be the end of the story
that's more or less the way i read it
and with no particular prescription
about
where it was going to go from here
so i mean this is probably the same with
all of you but if i was to count up the
uh the number of times that i've been
asked by members of the general public
okay do you really understand quantum
entanglement i think it's the question
i've been asked more than than any other
question
and i don't mean to get all meta on this
but i think the answer in part depends
on what one means by the term
understands right um we can make
predictions on and so forth but i mean
ono what's your view if someone
interrogates you and says do you
understand quantum entanglement
what do you say
yeah in fact this is something that i'm
i've been asked a lot of times by
family friends and in several talks
and
as you pointed out it's very interesting
the point that how do you do we
understand um
the understanding of the quantum
mechanics because sometimes
the most powerful
part of this
theories of quantum mechanics and the
developments further in the future like
quantum filtering and everything are the
extremely accurate predictions that they
have
uh
given us it's it's incredible how well
they work how
they allow us to
to make things work even in our normal
life the devices that we are using for
this conversation and everything
so i think it's that's a real
understanding how we can use this to
predict and to create new things but the
difficult part of this understanding is
how you transmit to the general audience
because when you want to transmit things
to the general audience you tend to use
metaphors or you know similarities with
real life
and as i said before this is not in our
daily intuition so then it's when it's
problematic like oh why what what is my
understanding of this when i compare it
with my daily life and yeah that's a
tricky part now
there is another tricky part of quantum
mechanics a kind of
gap in our understanding of quantum
mechanics sets
really just behind much of the territory
we've been discussing which is that
quantum mechanics describes reality as a
kind of
fuzzy haze of possibilities that only
resolves into the kind of definite
reality we all experience when the world
is observed or or measured or interacted
with in the right way and yet
our quantum mechanical understanding has
at least so far
not articulated how that transition from
fuzzy to definite how it actually
happens a transition that is of course
essential to entanglement since we're
talking about an observation here having
a spooky connection to an observation
over there now lenny
does this gap this so-called quantum
measurement problem
does it trouble you or do you see it as
more of a detail that we will one day
resolve
oh i don't think it's a detail by any
means i think it's at the very center of
all of the confusion about quantum
mechanics which i share i mean i don't
feel i understand quantum mechanics at
that level
and there was feynman who said i'm so
confused by the whole thing
that i can't even tell if there's a
problem
and
i think a lot of us feel that way
on the one hand we have to use quantum
mechanics we know that quantum mechanics
works if we want to make a theory of the
world it's got to be quantum mechanical
on the other hand we're so confused
about what the um
the basic
conceptual framework
of dividing the world into what's
observed and what's not observed
that uh that
i personally think there's there is
going to be another quantum revolution
that other quantum revolution is going
to come
to grips with this in a way that we
can't conceive of yet
but i also have the probably a lot of
people think that
okay my guess and i wouldn't be
surprised if um if mark shares it is
that we won't get that deeper
understanding until we understand the
relationship between quantum mechanics
and gravity quantum mechanics and the
geometry of the world
and we don't fully understand that yet
we're making a lot of progress
but
um i think it's not until then will we
have a chance at
understanding these deeper issues
that's a a great segue so why don't we
turn to gravity
general theory of relativity where we're
gonna ultimately take up a second of
einstein's 1935 papers so mark
einstein gives the world this beautiful
theory of gravity the general theory of
relativity where now
gravity is translated into geometry
warps and curves and space and time and
so forth a sort of beautiful
encapsulation of how the force of
gravity actually works 1919
it's confirmed or sort of confirmed
depending how you look at the history of
it through the bending of starlight by
the sun
but then interest in general relativity
seems to taper off i mean why was that
why wasn't that beginning why isn't that
beginning of a sort of new era of
gravitational study why did it sort of
begin to die away yeah that's a a good
question uh i i'm not sure i i know the
answer i mean i i'm guessing that
it was probably seen as uh still maybe a
little bit esoteric and mathematical and
difficult to
maybe compare with experiments that we
could readily
do in laboratories so it may have been
that uh it was still seen as just not
quite practical physics yet but maybe
maybe lenny wants to comment i live
through that era i'm old enough to have
been part of that era when
grown-up physicists didn't think grown
up in quotes physicists did not think
about general relativity
part of the reason
mark said part of it well that
that it was very very hard to get
experimental data about it
but
the other side of the coin is that it
was very easy to get lots and lots of
experimental data about other things
there were other fish to fry
there was
condensed matter physics
there was elementary particle physics
and so i think a large amount of it was
just physicists had other fish to fry
lots and lots of data and so it was kind
of natural that those who wanted to get
ahead who wanted to
do things who wanted to you know get
their hands on
and maybe win nobel prizes would be
going in the direction that um that
seemed
well that would seem like it was going
to yield to new theory
whereas gravity was beautiful it was
pristine it was um it was special
but there wasn't too much you could do
with it in the way of experimental data
it was just laid out there by einstein
and all its beauty and all its glory but
what do you do with it
so that was my understanding of it at
the time yeah
and so what about the 1935 paper he was
sort of uh okay so then the other that's
the other 19 you're talking about the
other 90 the other 1935 other 1935 paper
yeah i don't know what was on einstein's
mind frankly
um
he uh
he didn't like black holes
i don't even know if he knew in that
paper that he was talking about a pair
of black holes i'm not even sure that it
was actually einstein who cooked up the
uh the solution that we call einstein
rosen
um
he just as far as i can tell
he and rosen simply discovered a
solution of the einstein field equations
which uh contained this wormhole
connecting different regions of space
yeah yeah it connects two distant points
of space
with a tunnel
uh with a with a short tunnel
it's as if you could um
had a tunnel between new york and san
francisco and new york and palo alto
but if you go in the tunnel
it's only a mile and a half
inside the tunnel from one end to the
other
uh
so
exactly what was on his mind i don't
know
and certainly i am certainly convinced
that
he had no inkling at all about the
possible connection with the other 1935
paper yeah i mean we're gonna we're
gonna come to that in just a little bit
but
let's spend a little more time on black
holes which are intrinsic to the modern
day interpretation of the einstein rosen
bridges you know having two black holes
that are connected by a bridge
by this kind of throat and for our
conversation here perhaps the most
formative insight about black holes
comes to us from stephen hawking who
way back in the 1970s showed that black
holes are not as black as their name
suggests i mean hawking found that
when you include quantum effects black
holes can actually
radiate away particles from their edge
from their horizon so anna tell us what
is the idea here so hawking starting
thinking about
uh what's happening there in the in the
horizon so was using this um
theory this quantum field theory
to uh calculate what's happening with
the fields there
so then is um this uh simplified version
of thinking about it that is that in
this um
quantum field theory we allow for the
creation of particles
some uh when we consider this this is
when we consider quantum mechanics apply
to fields
and that you have um
more complex uh theory
and in this case you allow for this
creation of particles so it can be the
point that this creation of particles
takes place uh at the horizon of the
black hole so then one of the particles
falls into the black hole and the other
goes outside the black hole
being these particles entangle
as we have been discussing before
and
in this case what you have is like uh in
the end what do you find is that there
is some
radiation emitted by the black hole some
quantum emission
right so so just to summarize those
important points on according to quantum
mechanics
pairs of particles they can materialize
in empty space and although in ordinary
empty space those particles would then
quickly collide annihilating one another
near the horizon of a black hole once
its particle can fall in leaving its
partner free to fly off to radiate away
into space and as you also rightly
pointed out on this radiation brings
entanglement into the black hole story
because those pairs of erupting
particles are entangled that's a point
we're going to come back to in just a
moment but first mark
once we learn that black holes radiate
these particles that ana is making
reference to that there's actually stuff
that in some sense is coming out from a
black hole that stuff it takes away
energy and so the black hole gets
smaller in the process and will
ultimately disappear and this
raises a deep concern because the
fundamental principle in physics is that
information is never lost now when
something falls into a black hole right
if it's a book an iphone whatever you
might have imagined that the information
contained in the object
is not lost it's just inaccessible since
it's now
inside the black hole itself but when we
learn that black holes radiate and
ultimately disappear
that vision no longer works the black
hole can't hide the information forever
so the radiation better carry
that information back out with it but at
first blush
it doesn't seem that the radiation does
that giving rise to the so-called
black hole information problem or black
hole information paradox so mark can you
tell us about that and then we can
discuss
how lenny's going to solve it for us
yeah so
with
this black hole radiation that anna
described so you've got your black hole
what it looks like if you were to
measure what's coming out of the black
hole it looks just like say an object
with some temperature emitting the
thermal radiation
corresponding to that temperature and
one of the interesting things about
the detailed calculation that hawking
does is that
what comes out really doesn't care about
what formed the black hole what
what maybe collapsed to produce that
black hole in the first place it just is
the same kind of purely random
thermal radiation coming out and so
it it seems that you lose information uh
about what formed the black hole and
that's kind of in conflict with a basic
assumption or a basic property of
quantum mechanics in quantum mechanics
you could always sort of run the clock
backward you could recover
what it was that was the initial state
given this if you had complete knowledge
of the state later on and so there was a
tension there that if you
completely accepted um quantum hawking's
calculation then there seems to be a
tension with quantum mechanics and so
you could decide okay well you need to
modify quantum mechanics
if
if gravity is going to be a part of it
or you have to come up with some some
you know more
creative and brilliant idea
so lenny this loss of information
regarding what falls into a black hole
was a potential blow against all the
hard one understanding because according
to quantum mechanics no information is
ever lost according to quantum mechanics
a detailed form of radiation coming out
of a black hole should depend on what
fell in so
you and your comrade in arms gerard
the hardest of all names in physics to
pronounce you both were having none of
it and over the course of many years
you both developed your own versions of
similar arguments claiming that
information is not lost making use
of
incredibly strange but
wonderfully powerful idea known as the
holographic principle so
tell us how that goes and i gather that
string theory was an important
inspiration in your thinking here okay i
had had some experience in the field of
string theory and there was one thing
that had always puzzled me about string
theory
the more carefully you look at a quantum
string
the more precision that you bring to
bear on the measurement of the kind of
of the quantum string
the more you will find that it's spread
out over all of space
if you look at it
casually with not too great a resolving
power
you'll find the string localized a
little string a little particle you'll
find it localized in some localized
place
if you look at it more carefully with
more precision you will find out that
it's spread over a bigger distance if
you look at it really carefully you'll
find out that it's spread out over a
larger distance
it occurred to me
that when a particle falls into a black
hole somebody watching it from the
outside because
everything slows down
as a thing falls towards a black hole
its internal motions slow down
somebody watching it from the outside
gets to see it with more and more
precision
because it slows down
it's like looking at an airplane
propeller if it's going too fast you
can't see what it is
if it's slowed down you can get a look
at it and see what it is
and see it in more detail same thing
with this vibrating string
as it falls into a black hole somebody
watching it would get to see it with
better and better resolution
and therefore we get to see it spread
out more and more
in just such a way that instead of
falling into the black hole it would get
spread out not only over the horizon
but spread out
way out to infinity
and so i
just prayed on my mind i got to thinking
about it and had the idea
that somehow the fundamental degrees of
freedom and string theory are stored
very far away
and that the relationship between the
actual things that you see and the
actual storage of information was very
much like a hologram
uh at about the same time maybe even a
little bit earlier
my good friend that tuft had a very
similar idea
again that the information in a system
any system is stored far away at the
boundaries of the world
a very weird idea an extremely weird
idea
and um we got together we talked about
it
we both published articles on it
um
i was actually unaware of the fact that
he had used the term hologram in
describing this
earlier
and i called my paper the world as a
hologram
i think tufts paper got lost people
didn't notice it for some reason
the uh the bold uh title the world is a
hologram i think caught a few people's
attention at the time
so the idea was that information never
really falls into the black hole it's
always stored far away
but it's only the kind of um
image
of this information
that falls into the black hole
and can we think of the information as
being on the horizon echoing i think
that's one way of thinking about it but
you can even go further than that you
can say if you get enough resolution
power you will find that as you get
better and better resolution power it
sort of hovers above the black hole to
larger and larger distances away from
the black hole
uh where exactly is the horizon that
depends on how much detail you look at
it
where is the information it again
depends on what detail you look at it
with your resolving power of your camera
the speed of your camera if you like
it's not
uh in the black hole it's not on the
black hole ultimately
it's out at the boundaries of space
wherever the boundaries of space are
now the space have a boundary who knows
and so we come to a pretty wild state of
affairs
which seems to solve the problem right
information regarding whatever object
falls into a black hole is not lost
because that information gets stored
holographically outside the black hole
itself which in principle means that the
information is recoverable good but
then comes a paper
in 2012 by four physicists amiri marl
palchinsky and sully a paper referred to
in the field as amps
which shall we say
shocked the community and it has to do
with the entangled nature of the hawking
radiation that comes out of a black hole
which anna you
alluded to earlier namely
the erupting particles near the black
holes horizon are entangled but for the
outgoing radiation to embody
information about whatever fell in that
radiation can't be fully random instead
there also has to be entanglement
between the early radiation which is now
traveled far from the black hole
and later radiation which is still near
the black hole itself because
only with such entanglement
can there be information storage
now for
the problem that amps pointed out
quantum mechanics doesn't allow such
three-way entanglement cheekily referred
to in the field
as the monogamy of
entanglement
so
lenny
what to do
so mark's work was very very
instrumental in this
now what uh
before
yes
again i have to bring up another person
uh on this paper that i wrote that uh
that had to do with the two 1935 papers
for once in my life i was very
definitely the second author on a paper
the first author was juan maldasena who
had been thinking about very related
things for a long period of time
and uh
i i should mention that before we go any
further
okay so what uh what was i thinking
i had
i and also i think rafael busso had the
following idea
um
the information right behind the black
hole
right behind the horizon of the black
hole
let's see how to say this right
the exterior of the black hole cannot
both be
entangled with what's just behind the
horizon and the hawking radiation
unless
the information right behind the black
hole and in the hawking radiation are
the same thing
now that sounds again crazy
how can what's right behind the black
hole
is my black hole over here
okay then the hawking radiation is miles
and miles and miles no
many many many light years away
how can the information of what's right
behind the horizon of the black hole be
the same thing as the information in the
hawking radiation very very far away
nevertheless i said it must be true it
must be true that the entanglement is
not broken it's just that the
information right behind the black hole
is the same as in the hawking radiation
and that was my opinion that somehow in
some mysterious way the interior of the
black hole just behind the horizon
was really the same thing as the hawking
radiation very far away another nutty
idea that sounds somewhat similar to the
holographic idea
information that you thought was nearby
really very far away
uh juan maldasena and i got to talking
over the internet we started
collaborating and trying to figure out
what was going on with the amps paradox
at some point juan sent me a very
cryptic message
and in the cryptic message
he simply wrote down
e r equals epr
i knew instantly what he was talking
about
that's
that just was an explosion in my brain
when he said it i knew exactly what he
was talking about but he said it in such
a clear way now what did it mean
e.r stood feinstein rosen
e.p.r stephen einstein podolski rosen
remember what the two of them are
einstein rosen wormholes
epr entanglement
what he was saying
was
that if there's entanglement
then there must be wormholes connecting
the uh the regions that are entangled
if you took the whole thing together
what it seemed to say
was that there must be wormholes or a
wormhole
connecting the distant radiation
to the interior of the black hole
they're not as measured through the
wormhole they're really not very far
away
so that what we see as
radiation very very far from the black
hole
is connected through through a hidden
wormhole
to things just behind the horizon of the
black hole
that's what juan meant when he wrote
down er equals epr
that um
that if there's entanglement there must
be wormholes there must be spatial
connectivity
that in fact did turn out to be the
salute
as we believe that is the solution of
the amps paradox
that the entanglement
between the exterior and the interior is
not broken it just reappears as the
entanglement between the exterior of the
black hole and the hawking radiation
now einstein wrote those two papers like
two months apart
that's incredible
do you think that he had
any inkling that there is any connection
between them
no i don't think so there's no evidence
whatever
uh
and no i i do not think so
so it's another one of those
crazy examples where einstein is just
somehow able to put his finger on things
that that that last didn't matter
um i think i i really think this is just
accidental
but who can say
einstein was was extraordinarily unusual
but he wasn't supernatural and i don't
think he could have um
he didn't have all the things which were
necessary to um
to formulate
a reason for connecting those two ideas
yeah yeah absolutely so mark lenny made
reference to your work that played an
important role in the remarkable results
that he was just recounting
i i want to finish up with our our final
scientific subject to to explore that
insight of yours a little bit
and maybe we can do it in two pieces
because part of it makes use of an
insight of juan maldasena the physicist
that lenny made reference to
this uh generalized version if you will
of holography you know describing some
region of space by degrees of freedom
and physics that lives on a boundary if
you can give us a uh just an intuitive
sense of of that first and then we can
go on to how that insight is then
leveraged into this result about how
space is held together by quantum
entanglement
yeah so
i think that the
the way i would describe holography is
the idea that
what you see in a gravitational
universe um is really not
it's somehow encoded in a system
that's more fundamental that's not
really present in that universe at all
so
it does happen to have the same geometry
as the boundary of space and some
examples but i think maybe the more
general idea is that you've got
some kind of more or less ordinary
quantum system
that doesn't have gravity in some of the
examples it's
basically you can imagine a spherical
shell of some exotic material
and that thing is able to encode
the physics of a gravitational universe
and then there's a basic question well
how does it
do that how does how do you store the
information about
geometry of space and the presence of
black holes and radiation all this how
is that stored in this much simpler kind
of quantum system
and
we've eventually come to an
understanding that actually thinking
about this story of entanglement is
really important for understanding how
is that information about gravity
encoded in this in this more ordinary
system so cena gave a really interesting
example
where he wanted to describe
not just a
a single ordinary black hole but
a kind of more
exotic
that is basically the one that einstein
and rosen thought about so
one way to describe that is you have a
black hole
in
one universe or one part of a universe
and another black hole and maldocino was
thinking about the case where that was
in an entirely disconnected separate
universe
and so there's this configuration where
geometrically those two things are
connected such that if
one person went into the horizon of one
black hole and another person from the
other universe went into the horizon of
another black hole they could they could
meet in the middle so there's a spatial
connection between these things
and so while the cena said um how do we
describe this thing using this
holographic approach
and he says because there's two
universes that you know otherwise apart
from this wormhole
they're just separate universes well
this should involve two copies two sets
of uh two copies of this quantum system
that we were talking about before so you
can imagine having two of these
spherical shells
and he says that if you want to build
one of the wormholes well you put a lot
of energy in one to get a black hole you
put a lot of energy in the other to get
a black hole in the other space-time but
then you entangle them
in this very special way
and that's the only thing that connects
them and he says well this is the
natural description in quantum mechanics
of that space time where you have the
two parts of the two universes connected
by a wormhole and uh it just struck me
that really because this entanglement is
the only thing
that makes these two systems have
anything to do with one another
then
maybe that's the thing that is just
directly responsible for creating this
wormhole as i said you did a study
theoretical study of course where
you were kind of snipping
the threads of quantum entanglement
and recognizing its impact on the
connectivity
of space and that to me really brings it
home so you can describe how that goes
yeah
yeah so i was wondering you know is this
something that is
specific to this black hole space time
that's kind of an exotic thing having
two universes connected by a wormhole
so is the is it that entanglement makes
these exotic wormholes or
is it just the more basic thing that
entanglement is the thing that is
responsible for any space being
connected with any other space and so
what i thought to do was just look at a
simpler example where you go to the case
where you just have
one of these quantum mechanical systems
describing a completely boring empty
space time so just like we were talking
about with the near the black hole
horizon you have an ordinary kind of
empty patch of space there's lots of
entanglement between the fields here and
the fields here so that's the same in
these holographic quantum mechanical
systems they have lots of entanglement
between the left side of this
ball and the right side of the ball and
so i wondered what would happen if you
envisioned
altering the state altering this state
you'd have to add energy but to you add
energy in such a way that it removes
entanglement between two sides you can
kind of follow it through and ask what
happens to the space time and it seemed
that as you removed entanglement between
one side and the other
then what happens to the space-time is
it kind of pulls itself apart
like like pulling a piece of gum apart
it gets you know thinner the connection
and eventually would snap and be
basically just two disconnected pieces
once you've removed the entanglement
from the underlying quantum system and
then you can just keep doing that and
now you'd have two pieces now you could
divide up this
ball into more pieces remove the
entanglement between those further
pieces
and if you just kept going and going it
seems that on the gravity side you
really have nothing left at all and so
when you say there's no when you say
there's nothing there at all
i gather you mean that in some sense
spacers keeps cutting up into smaller
and smaller kind of pixelates to the
point where no connectivity is left and
it's just gone
yeah that's that's right so you just
have
you know we think of maybe space as
being the background
for
everything else but with einstein
space became a dynamical entity
and then you could start to ask the
question maybe where does it come from
is it always there and this picture this
holographic picture suggests that
even space
in order to exist you need quantum
entanglement between these underlying
physical entities so it's it's kind of
bizarre like we went into
studying string theory and holography to
really to understand quantum gravity
and then
when you get to this kind of observation
it suggests that even if you're trying
to understand classical gravity
then
there's quantum mechanics behind that
yeah that takes us to our to the final
question i wanted to ask that's a
perfect segue in so so on a final
question that i'd like everyone to weigh
in on
in traditional approaches to quantum
mechanics the way we often teach it to
our students is we have a classical
system and then we quantize it we
employ certain rules of quantum
mechanics to take whatever system that
we might be studying using newton's
equations and translate it into a system
using schrodinger's equation you know
the quantum degrees of freedom now when
we've tried to do that straightforwardly
with gravity we've always run into
headaches which is what has motivated
approaches that many people follow from
loop quantum gravity to string theory
and so forth
now we're learning that
in some sense quantum mechanics
knows about
space
space at quarter einstein is the arena
it's warps and curves of space that give
rise to gravity so in some sense quantum
mechanics seems to know about gravity
so is that quality of quantum mechanics
that was overlooked for a long time
do you think that might have been the
reason why we had such trouble using the
standard quantization rules and trying
to apply them to gravity itself
what happened at least to me in the last
years and inspiring all the proposals
that they have mentioned is that
i'm not sure if it's coming from quantum
mechanics as a basic setup that has a
control over what happens there but what
is nowadays clear is that
quantum mechanics is giving us
the necessary tools
to understand
this connection between
gravity and
quantum realm in the sense of this
precisely this entanglement so
lenny big picture
people have been trying to put gravity
and quantum mechanics together for a
long time you've of course spearheaded
the most um insightful approach to that
which is string theory
does these recent developments do they
they change your thinking on the
relationship between quantum mechanics
and gravity i think what's going on and
i very strongly believe what's going on
is that quantum mechanics and gravity
are simply so deeply connected so
intimately connected
uh so inseparable
that trying to separate them into the
classical theory of gravity and quantum
mechanics
will inevitably lead and then put them
back together again separate them into
these two things and then put them back
together by the procedure of
quantization
will
just be the wrong thing
except that quantum mechanics and
gravity are almost the same thing or
that they're at least so closely linked
that you can't pull them apart
and you will never be led to the idea of
trying to quantize gravity
uh
so
yes my opinion is that that's the
direction things are going in
and it's why i said in the beginning
that perhaps the ultimate mysteries of
quantum mechanics
will only be revealed when we much
better understand the connection with uh
with gravity
but we'll see
yeah absolutely
so it's been a fascinating conversation
covered a lot of ground
motivated by einstein's 1935 papers and
it's an exciting
time in physics and who knows where it's
all going to lead but it's so remarkable
to me that we're actually talking about
things like what is space made of the
kind of question that like as a high
school kid
many of us worried about and thought
about but never thought there'd be any
insight so
congratulations all the work that you
have all spearheaded to push the
frontiers forward and thank you so much
for spending some time today to talk
about it
[Music]
so
[Music]
you